Hey, it's Becca here.
Welcome again to my channel.
In today's video
I've got some good news and some clarification
for all immigrants who are in the UK.
The government came out to leave
5 points immigration plans
that was supposed to be used to keep immigration.
But guess what,
somewhere, somehow
this 5 points immigration plans affected
directly indirectly
everybody who was in the UK.
Either mean
it's on the skill worker visa
or the student visa.
Even the British citizens ask me why.
Because there are some British citizens who are Martin
non British
and are looking forward to bringing them over
or to renewing their visa in the UK.
And if the sorry threshold was raised,
it means that they would also be affected.
And I really acknowledge
the effort of the Scottish Prime Minister
that he put in,
in addition to other people
once welcomed many immigrants,
including my grandfather,
to the country.
In fact, they begged them to come
and others to come to work in their factories,
to drive the buses,
due to labour shortages that were seen at that time.
And what successive UK governments have done,
Labour and conservative,
is that they have bit by bit
dismantled on immigration
and the deedar asylum processes. On.
On immigration.
The latest announcements mean that we are asking
the UK government
is asking migrants to come here
to look after our own family members,
but doing so by abandoning their own family members
back home. Listen,
the NHS immediately came out to say that
their workers or their staff
are exempt from this dependent issue,
meaning that if you are coming to work for the NHS,
you were allowed to bring in your dependent.
Is from the NHS Employers website,
which I am reading,
published on December 5th.
When the changes take effect,
care workers and senior care workers
be unable to bring their dependent
when they might go to the UK.
And only CQC register providers in England
will be able to sponsor health and care visa applicants.
These changes do not affect the NHS.
Following this news,
we have been tracing
to see is all the things that were said.
There was no clarity.
People were asking questions.
You guys were in. My dear,
I can't even know how to address this.
They were asking, Becca,
what if I'm in the UK already?
What if my spouse is here with me?
Can we bring our children?
What time is this taking effect?
Becca, what is the salary threshold?
Becca, if I'm in the care of my affected?
I myself didn't know
some of the answers to these questions,
but guess what?
The Parliament has come out again
with more clarity
to some of the things that they have stated.
There are some of the things that still needs clarity
which we are still waiting on.
The first question is
when would the changes happen?
That is going to happen in next spring.
But they Are not sure
whether it's going to be early next spring,
mid next spring
or late next spring.
As we all know,
spring starts from March,
which is officially the 19th of March.
Spring begins
and it ends
somewhere in may.
So it's like
a 2 months period.
They are not sure whether it's going to be
the first week in spring,
mid spring, late spring,
early spring,
whatever. It is
not definitive,
but what they are saying is
that they are going to be making statements of change.
And so it's gonna be like
a one month notice period
for this changes to take effect.
So when we are approaching spring,
they're going to be bringing
out this statement of change,
telling us the exact date
and after that
they're not going to give any further reminder.
So when that date reaches,
that is going to be taking effect.
So that is point number one is clear.
So they're gonna be giving us a statement of change,
which gives you a 21 notice,
a 21 days notice period
for all these changes to take place.
So what we are approaching
there will hear
the statement of change
and after that statement of change,
at least 21 days,
we should expect
all of these changes to take place.
You are wondering
is there going to be a vote in Parliament
to either debunk these changes or not?
They're saying that no,
there are no active.
No voting gonna be happening.
Once this has been implemented
or once it's been agreed upon,
is that a house of Commons
or house of Lords
actively vote
or raise a concern
that it will be looked into,
but otherwise
nothing is going to be changing.
So they're saying that
if there is a debate on changes to the immigration rule,
the proposed changes
cannot be amended.
They can either be accepted
or voted down
in their entirety.
No further legislation is needed.
It means that
either the house of Commons
or the house of Lords
has a concern,
and even if they do have a concern,
they're either going to be voted it
to come into full effect
or they're going to be voted it
to be turned down entirely
but not to be amended.
Next question,
is my constitute to be
extending their
spouse and partner visa
after spring 2024
with a 38,700 trash
or apply to them
or only for first time visa applicant?
So let's say
like for we immigrants,
you are in the UK already,
you are due to
change over your visa.
I do to switch
over your visa.
I do to apply for
the dependent to switch.
You are asking
is this change going to affect you
if you are in
the UK already
and the answer is no.
This change is going to be
forward looking.
It means that it's going to be taking
effect from
only those that
are yet to come into the UK
after Spring.
Even if you're
coming to the UK
from now to spring,
you are not affected.
Once your leg has touched
the ground of UK
before the spring
that is going to be
taking effect,
you are not
affected by
this change.
Is going to be
forward looking.
It means that
only those that are
coming from after
the change is
implemented
after spring,
they are the only people
that it is going to affect.
So either you're in
the UK already,
you're looking to
switch your visa,
apply for a
dependent visa extension,
or you're looking
for to come into
the UK before spring.
None of these
applies to you.
You are still going by
the old room.
It's only those that
are coming into
the UK after
all these bucket changes have been implemented
are going to be
affected. Okay,
so it means
that if you are
coming to U.
K. After the changes have been implemented
then you are going to be looking
at a £38,700
threshold for
either bring
you dependence
or for either
visa extension.
Accept you are in the NHS.
Accept you are in
the NHS. Also
some people
are asking um
can I combine
my husband and I?
We are both in the UK,
we are looking
for to extend.
As I said it doesn't
apply to you.
But if I just wondering
if you are coming
after all these changes
and you are
coming with
your spouse
or you want to come
With your husband,
how do you go
about things?
Will you still meet
the 38,700 threshold?
Will you be able to bring
your children with this?
All they are
saying here
is that if you are
coming in the UK
after the spring,
these changes
are going to be
affecting you.
And then if you are
applying from
overseas, you
the main applicant,
you are the only person
whose salary
is going to be considered
with this threshold.
It means that
if you are coming in
initially, they
are going to be looking at
your salary,
the 38,700. If
you are not a nurse,
if you are not a doctor,
or if you are not
another health
and care visa
with the NHS
and you are
coming into the UK,
they will look at
your salary
as the main
applicant, you know,
making sure
that it meets
that £38,700
if you want to break
your family.
But if you're
coming alone
and you are
kind of a health
and care visa
as a carer, they will
not consider that.
But when you've come into
the UK already
and you bring
your spouse
or you have
here with you,
then you can
do the joint
application
or you can do
the joint salary.
Trash hold. You
can put your
salaries together
to make sure that
you both of
your salaries
exceed thirty
eight thousand
seven hundred pounds
that you can bring
like your children.
So you have to make Sure
that you provide
pays for that
everyday. Is that
this salary
has been, you know,
achieved or accrued
for the past 6
months, in which
paid this money
for the past 6 months
for you and
your spouse.
So let me read
what it says
here. It says
when applying
for the initial visa
from outside
the UK, only
the sponsors income
will be counted
towards the minimum
income threshold.
For extensions
and permanent residence,
both incomes
are counted.
So if you are in
and you're looking
for extensions,
you're looking for
permanent residence,
then both of
your incomes
will be considered.
But if you're
coming in for
the first time,
it is only the
main applicant
whose income
will be considered.
People generally
to provide evidence
of having earned
that income
for the past six
months. Although
the exact rules
are complicated.
That is what they
are saying. So
we all know that
these rules
are complicated
and day in, day
out, who keep
affording them
one at a time.
There are also
some options
for people who
do not earn
the minimum income,
allowing them to qualify
for the visa
by other means,
such as using savings
above 16,000
or an exceptional
circumstances.
The Home Office says
this will still
be possible
once the threshold rises.
So if you're
able to prove
that you've got
a savings of
above £16,000,
even if you
do not meet
this 38,700,
you can still bring
your dependent.
It Means that
you come in,
you have to look smart,
you have to work hard
and save up
to that 16,000.
If your salary
doesn't meet
the 38,700, you
can still bring in
your family
and your dependence.
So all that they
are saying is
that whatever
is gonna happen,
this rules are
gonna happen
after it is
implemented
in spring. And also,
if you are in
the UK already,
all these changes we
are talking about,
or we've spoken about,
are not going to be
applying to you.